Where'd the game go?
Oh, there's the game.
We're fine.
Hello everybody.
Hi.
I'm here with my mummy.
I don't know what.
I thought that was so funny.
I should have gotten in the bed too.
What a beautiful view.
Do you guys know that clip?
I like the view.
You're my best view.
Me.
The music, the new music is very chill.
No, thank you so much for the peep.
Thank you to thank you.
Hope you like cartoon horses.
Yeah, everybody, welcome to Mouthwashing!
This game was like the popular game last year.
And it's my turn to try it.
Close to one year anniversary of it, the three-point.
I know!
Sorry, physical therapy.
You got this!
Sorry, I can't...
I can't scroll up and you guys are sending so many things but thank you thank you thank you see that recently good smile announced the anya mouthwashing android i did i know it's kind of crazy because i was just like what should i play for something spooky and i was like you know i've never done mouthwashing so i i have brushed my teeth but but um but um yeah i was like maybe i could try it.
It's a little spooky.
I'm imagining you guys laughing like Tidus Titus, Final Fantasy X.
The Nendroid of her looks so cute though.
I will say I did watch a streamer play this game before.
But it was like one of those things.
where it's like I had them on in the background.
I don't really remember the game.
I don't think I paid attention like at all.
So, um, yeah, second monitor, uh, behavior there.
I don't even, I couldn't even tell you who I watched, to be honest.
I just remember having it on.
I don't even remember who it was.
So...
Uh...
So, no spoilers, I suppose.
Because it was...
Nimmy probably?
No, it was before Nimmy debuted.
Don't go assuming, I watch lots of people.
But I really don't remember.
It wasn't even a VTuber, you guys.
Stop asking.
I told you, I don't remember.
But I know it wasn't a V-Tuber.
It was a flesh person.
Feel this game.
Wait, is this game messed up in addition to scary?
I think it's messed up.
Right.
It's messed up.
Annoying Orange.
Oh my gosh, yes, it was annoying Orange.
Thank you.
but we're we're gonna have some fun with uh um some psychological horror then you're gonna see david hater have fun he's so nice
annoying orange is a vtuber no no he's an orange duh but cool i guess uh we'll just start i don't know why says continue I did not start a game but um I was trying to get my mouse mouth mouth oh my gosh I almost said mouth because mouthwashing my mouse sensitivity it seems okay right now so psychological horror I'm going crazy I'm going crazy it's so beautiful though it can't this is this seems so chill it can't be that scary It can't be that bad.
How's the audio, by the way?
Oh, Pony Express Long Haul Space Fighter Topar.
Crew 5.
Planned shipment duration 382 days.
Like, are those space days or elapsed transit time?
147 days.
I hope this hurts.
Oh, okay.
Yowch.
Someone, someone, someone accidentally was writing their feelings in the logbook again.
They mixed up the logbook in their diary.
Whoa!
Zero days before the crash.
Uh-oh.
An orbital bot... Or... An orbital... Wait, no.
Sorry.
An orbital body has been detected 21 AU ahead of the vessel.
Please make a manual correction 1.4 degree leftwards to avoid impact with unknown mass.
Oh, gosh.
I have to do that.
What's the big red button do?
It's slacked.
Okay.
Give me now.
This thing here.
Steer right.
Leave.
Steer right, no?
Trying to... Wait, or does this... Wait, does this bring us to the crash?
Oh, wait.
Oh, by bad.
Wait a second.
Extreme warning!
Direct collision course with orbital body 1.9 AU away.
Iceberg dead ahead!
Reaching autopilot to re-correct vessel.
Advise crew to take up emergency positions.
4,000 credits docked from crew pay package for failure of navigational staff.
My Christmas bonus.
Okay, why did I do that?
It's locked.
Okay, it's still...
Oh, oh, I can...
Oh.
length of nylon rope those are am i oh take the emergency key am i the bad guy
danger pony express protection kit use only in case of emergency captain access only code scan or require oh am i the captain i have access an emergency generator Uh, what's over here?
There's nothing else to be done.
Okay, can I leave?
I can't let anyone in.
Okay.
This autopilot sure has taken a long time.
Emergency cockpit console, override key!
Disengage autopilot.
Everybody!
Oh, wait, I can leave.
Polly says, don't be daft.
Don't be daft.
You'll cause a draft.
And then you'll catch a cold.
Where are we going?
What's this one?
Polly says, rise and shine.
Polly says, lend a hand.
Lend a hand.
So many doors.
Yeah, like, what's the point?
Oh, I guess maybe it's like a protective thing, right?
Well, we're about to crash anyway.
What's it?
There's something behind this door.
Oh, just kidding.
Wait, I'm scared.
Wait, I've got it scared.
I thought that was someone down the hall.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, is...
Oh!
Giddy up, Galaxy.
Well, I hear something, I feel.
Don't be daft, rise and shine, lend a hand.
Giddy up, Galaxy.
Is something chasing me or what there's...
Okay, I'm hearing my own footsteps.
Well, there's two ways we could... Oh, just kidding.
Crash is imminent, but I guess not soon enough.
So many posters.
Well, I think it really livens up the place, don't you think?
Oh.
I mean, I'm kind of scared.
Don't be daft.
I'm kind of scared.
I thought you guys said this was more...
Ah!
Oh.
Don't be daft.
A galaxy...
What was it?
Galaxy?
Oh, Gideon of Galaxy!
Maybe...
Do I have to tell his favorite one?
Do I hear babies cry?
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Why is it now blinking?
Oh, God.
Is he gone?
Okay, I'm just gonna do that.
It's spooky, wait.
What are we gonna crash?
Please!
I'm stuck on board with a haunted horse!
Oh Uh-oh I'm guessing it's telling me to go this way instead Well, there's nothing down there anyway Ah Oh, maybe This is why the thing could be done Our ship Spooky
Wait, he's...
Can I go around?
Can I get around Jipali?
Oh, yeah, he's got like...
He's like fused together.
Alright.
I'll just ignore him real quick.
Wait, wait.
Wait, did it change?
Am I crazy?
Am I going the right way?
Was there a door here?
No.
Wait, did I shut this?
Am I crazy?
She's crazy.
I shot this one.
I can't get around him.
Excuse me.
Let me through, please.
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
Oh, wait.
It shut again.
Crouch jump.
You can't jump in this game.
Maybe I go back.
this way I'm already locking I'm already what's it called but oh no oh no no oh no no what
there's so many oh gosh there's so many ways to go I don't think the ship is supposed to fall apart before the crash right I don't think that's what's supposed to happen.
Unless we knew the ship was falling apart.
Hey, let me in!
Oh, two months after the crash, we lived!
Wait.
Oh, it's because we landed in the ocean.
Oh my goodness.
I don't know what voice to give Jimmy, because I'm not sure which one one is Jimmy.
Anyone else would do the same thing.
Oh.
Swansea.
We ain't touching the damn cargo.
The hold is locked down for a reason.
The only thing worse than dying slowly is not getting paid.
So true.
Oh, I'm Jimmy.
Okay, okay, okay.
But it could be something useful, I think.
Could be what?
Hope's dreams and Marzipan.
Marzipan.
More is a pain.
Ha!
You don't have to.
If it helps us survive, it's worth it.
Man, Pony Express bosses really aren't chill at all.
It just gives off shaggy vibes.
How exactly is this group therapy committee planning on getting in there?
Okay, I'm gonna... I think I'm gonna give up the voices.
Is that okay?
I'll try and do some of them, but for some reason I thought this game was voiced.
Maybe because I listened to somebody voice it.
Oh, right here, boss.
You're looking at the meanest swing of the regional junior baseball team.
Straight up nearly corked a kid once.
Why?
Why is that shaking?
Worked, kid.
I can take the utility action.
You were goddamn born fully corked.
That's enough, Swansea.
There has to be an in-case-of-emergency way inside.
If I remember correctly from the safety protocols, the doors should have an alternate access code.
but it can only be uncovered using a code scanner device and only the captain has access to the scanner of course go ahead and ask him all about it then maybe he'll sing you the blues too I like the text effects we don't need them if we find the scanner get the code and open the hold for better or worse I'm captain Oh,
okay.
Swansea is a literal thumb with a face.
Don't say that.
I see it now.
I'll figure it out.
Right on.
Okay, so he's kind of got like a surfer attitude instead.
Nomestar runner reference.
I kind of, I see thumb and I also see like, a worm.
Acquire code scanner.
Alright, baby.
Oh, this guy, this guy, this guy literally haunting my dreams.
They actually sell plushies of this guy for kids.
Oh, he doesn't say, he only says one thing?
Polly says lend a hand.
Teamwork is the soul of success.
When you have completed your tasks, always check on other tasks.
tasks.
HR complaints about poor team synergy may result in collective punishment.
Collective punishment?
Polly says rise and shine.
Sleep is the best rest after a long day of work.
Earn that rest.
Don't overdo it or fall behind.
Do not indulge in over five hours of rest.
That's indulging five hours of rest.
Polly says get it up galaxy.
Punctual delivery is our pride and promise, no matter where you are.
Late deliveries will be docked from personal credits.
Polly says, don't be daft.
Proper preparation prevents accidents.
It is your responsibility to keep yourself and the crew safe.
Medical expenses will be docked from personal credits.
Oh my gosh!
Whoa!
So we've all been sleeping in here.
Good thing we had extra medical mattresses.
The floor isn't that bad.
Who's reading gaming mat?
Okay, this has got to be Daisuke's bed.
He's got a Game Boy and some weights and gaming magazine.
is a toothbrush, I guess?
Oh, whoa, sorry.
Insulation foam that was automatically discharged when the hole breached.
Locked off the compromised parts of the ship and kept us alive.
Whoa!
Whoa.
What's here?
Gelatin?
Sounds like my kind of meal.
Water?
Restricted item?
Captain Axe is only...
It says sweetener.
How is that...
Tonic?
Cake recipe?
Mix water and gelatin.
Mix cake base and sweetener.
Enjoy Pony Express standard celebration cake.
Drink recipe.
Water and tonic.
Drink, base, and sweetener.
Enjoy Pony Express specialty mocktail drink.
Oh, whoops, my bad.
I forget it's right click.
Okay.
I guess I'll be making...
I'll be baking later.
It's a piece of cake to bake, I eat a cake.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, my...
Before we go there, okay, so I can run.
Oh, here's our food.
Spaghetti?
We'd be dead without this thing.
Never thought I'd be thankful for Pony Express Grub.
Coffee!
This machine was empty even before the crash.
Swansea sawed that.
Aw.
Never mind.
This room is like, how...
You can't... I have to squint in here.
Ugh.
Looks like it'll be soup again for dinner you want a rock paper scissors for the chicken noodle how much food do we have left i'd say like four months ish less than the remaining air supply but we can make it last in theory we'll be starting to poke new holes in our belts pretty soon to pull that off man my mom will straight up stuff me when i get back it'll look like swansy We'll have a rad story to tell them.
They might even write articles about us.
We could be on TV.
So this is in space.
Well, we crashed.
Somewhere.
It'll impress the ladies too.
Oh!
Hell yeah.
The real problem is us running out of toilet paper.
Fatal stuff, man.
leave that part out for the press.
Agreed.
Okay, so he's like a hymbo.
Oh, that's the gaming magazine.
What the?
Clown Mania.
Yeah.
Oh, my eyes, though.
My...
Oh, my gosh.
What's this way?
Whoa.
Okay, so we're We're looking for the scanner.
Oh,
how relaxing.
This room got messed up.
These are all we have left.
Take the pa- Wait, it won't- it doesn't- wait.
It won't let me click leave.
Wait.
Oh, did I take it on accident?
This vent has been busted forever, at least according to Swansea.
Probably beyond wrecked now.
I can hear him breathing.
He's staring at me.
He's behind my head, though.
You guys can't see him, but he's staring at me.
He doesn't want to keep still anymore.
I'm sorry.
He does not have any skin.
He has no choice.
What about the painkillers?
It just hurts him so much.
I can't stand the noise.
You did make it through nursing school.
right a nursing school does not does not prepare you for for skinned man yeah this is just the beginning of of metal gear solid v pony express sure does know how to cut corners if nothing else anya's so cute um i was thinking we never went back into the cockpit after we dragged him out So it was him!
It's almost entirely foamed up.
Kind of a miracle Curly didn't end up fossilized.
But it could still be unstable.
I just think, well, it's the only place the code scanner could still be.
Otherwise, we're shit out of luck.
I'll take a look.
I know you'll figure it out, Jimmy.
You're so capable.
I don't You're You're so capable Jimmy I would believe her if it wasn't all like woozy like that Oh also Well um I was hoping you could help me with Captain Curly
Okay Jimmy Okay Uh Guy's still alive right?
I mean he's the captain Okay Just because you took over, you said you'll claim to be captain.
Okay, Jimmy.
His little power trip is already starting.
Right, sorry.
With Curly's medication.
People have to be worth their titles.
Don't you think?
Nurse Anya?
Oh, no!
We suck!
Yeah.
Forget I asked.
I'll take care of it.
I don't want...
I don't
want...
Wow, they...
It just...
It just peeled off.
It's like...
Like a potato grater was taken down.
My goodness.
Oh!
Can you talk?
Ah!
Oh my god.
Oh, it...
Pill time.
10 billion.
Oxycodone.
Extended release capsules.
The good stuff.
Old still, yeah?
Wait, I don't want to do this.
I don't like this any more than you do.
Oh, gosh.
Yum, jerky.
You know what they say.
Pain is how we know we're still living.
I can't bear to listen.
Excuse me, sorry.
Wait, listen to what?
What?
It makes me want to breeze.
Controversial opinion here.
I don't want to be skinned.
Like you were next on the list.
Curly ASMR.
I mean wouldn't it be more humane to like put him out of his misery?
I don't know man.
Oh gosh.
Doesn't get a signal anymore.
Unfortunately Anya and Swansea's playlists survive the crash.
This is nice music!
You're such a hater, Jimmy.
Oh, no.
Are you okay?
I'm checking on you, not as Jimmy, but as Minto.
We don't have a whole lot of painkillers left.
Yeah, that'll be fine.
But you still want to keep...
Why do you think he did it?
Does it matter?
What answer would make you feel any better?
I have to believe that our worst moments don't make us monsters, Jim.
I have to, even in this case.
He tried to take us all down with him, Anya.
The way I see it, there's two reasons to keep him alive at this point.
I guess the important bit is that we all agreed to it, for one reason or another.
I'm still feeling nauseous.
I need a minute.
Where'd you go?
You know what, let's not bother her.
Lysuke, why don't you help out of her?
Has Swansea been like this towards you for your whole internship?
That's just how he is, man.
Didn't want to spud like me following him around for an entire year.
The way Curly looks makes me think of Naraku from Yuna Yasha before he became a demon.
Oh, no.
to become consumed with his rage.
This isn't really the internship experience anyone had in mind.
He's getting great, uh, great experience.
He can, he'll be able to put all of this on his resume.
uh, overcoming, uh, difficult hurdles, uh, uh, problem solving, uh, uh, Oh gosh, it's been so long since I've done a resume.
Yeah, crisis management experience, patience, and having to be resourceful with supplies, team building.
You got this, you got this, Jimmy.
I mean, Daisuke?
Don't let him push you around too much.
His bark is worse than his bite.
He may be cranky, but he is legit a wizard of a mechanic.
I was like, you rock!
This is what years and years and years and years of experience looks like.
I'm sure he appreciated that.
Yeah, his resume is about to be stacked, baby.
Hello, Minto.
Hi!
Hello, hello.
So medical.
Right on, daddy.
Thanks for the five.
Thank you for the five gifted!
Thank you.
Before we go that way, because it seems kind of...
Far.
What's in here?
Oh, okay, never mind.
We do want to go.
Wait, what was over here?
Everything points to this way.
Nothing important, I suppose.
Why is this room like so 70s looking?
Okay.
They're making Curly barbecue when the food runs out.
Oh, no!
Don't say that!
Beef jerky for all.
Well, they did say there was less food than air available.
Oh, this also leads...
Oh, so it's a circle.
Hi, Anya.
She's so cute.
Thank you for helping with Curly.
Did you find the code scanner?
I hope it's still there.
The cockpit is covered in...
phone.
I haven't checked.
Is this it?
No, there's no zero!
I can't put in eight, zero, zero, eight.
It's the universal unlock code.
It's like the Konami code of codes.
Membita.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Captain has been equipped with a standard issue code scanner to unlock the door.
Oh yeah, okay.
This is the lounge.
Where were we then if this is the lounge?
Okay, we're going up.
Wow, what a cozy, very not claustrophobic.
Oh.
Not claustrophobic.
place.
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
I was like, there's got to be something else.
Swansea.
Ain't you supposed to be figuring out our great cargo robbery?
Why are you standing out here?
None of your goddamn business.
Everything is my business now because of Curly.
I don't want to keep having this conversation.
Everyone is such good friends here, huh?
Right, right.
Cap... Cap... Cap... Cap... Cap...
Retino.
I'm working.
Blue-collar fools can't afford to stop working, even when the machine does.
Go figure.
And before you start, I'm taking a break.
Don't you worry.
I ain't going over my break time allowance.
Ha!
Working on what?
How does it look in there?
It's a solid wall of foe.
Swansea seems like Kiso.
How?
I'm trying to see if I can break it down enough to get something useful out, any of my tools.
But if I breach that foam and break the air seal, it's lights out for all of us.
I ain't letting anyone else mess around in there.
Even Daisuke?
He's your intern.
He's supposed to be helpful.
You think I'm letting that knucklehead in here after the crash roughed it up?
Our so-called nurse nearly skewered her leg when the vent hatch was open during maintenance.
And that crash i warned her but it's in one ear and out the other then there's that teeny bopper thinking only with his downstairs long nose he's in space what is there to think about
don't we all a downstairs long nose like squidward just like Like my useless kids back home.
You have a...
You have kids?
So no.
Ain't letting anyone mess around in here.
Alright, Swansea.
Keep me updated.
Okay.
Well...
So I'm guessing the big room...
Okay.
Where Anya was standing.
I thought it was the cockpit at first.
But it is...
It's the store like the storage where they keep all the packages.
Oh, it's not so foamed up in here, surprisingly.
Open the cargo hall.
That's the word.
Wait, it's actually like not so bad in here.
A length of rope.
Why not need that for something?
protection kit is there anything we can grab in here or look at or anything no okay
this pipe must have broken off during the crash I can barely see it, it's so dark okay, cool thank you so much for the five gifted dag oh you always have a new profile file picture.
Alright, baby.
Oh.
Swansea hasn't let anyone in utility since the crash.
It says it's filled with foam.
Is it?
Or is he just building a secret fort in there?
No girls allowed.
Oh, hello, everybody.
I'm glad we could all gather.
Well, get on with it.
This is all you.
I want it duly noted that no involvement in this no grills allowed what do you guys think we've been shipping if it's spare parts maybe me and Swansea can repair the ship and we can get out of here oh my gosh he has a brain right Swansea quit yapping his
his shirt does look kind of like goofy no like his he looks like looks like Charlie brown a little bit.
Is that the... Oh, wait!
You're wearing one, too!
That's just the uniform.
Anya's not, though.
She has fashion sense.
Are we doing the right thing?
Let it be medicine, food, or water.
Here I go.
Wait.
Scan, scan, scan, scan, scan, scan.
How do I... How do I scan?
I don't know the code.
Wait.
Tab.
tab.
Used to reveal access code across the Tollpar.
Oh!
Oh, this?
No?
Wait.
Across where?
Toriko, thank you for the vibe.
Get that in.
Touch you, oh my gosh.
Thank you for the 20 gifts.
Thank you so much!
Across where?
The black bar.
It is the black bar?
Okay, that's what I thought.
Ah, here we go.
seven.
Okay, cool.
What if it...
Whoa, there's so much in here.
What if it was, like, exploded, though, you know?
Oh.
What's happening?
Oh!
Gosh, I thought my game just...
Seven days before the crash.
Are you listening?
Yeah, yeah.
Damn.
I'm so sorry.
Couldn't sleep again.
But I passed the Psyche Val.
well you gave the same answers as last time i do wish you'd open up a little more captain these evaluations aren't just about you how i can't i the only way i know how he looks is like like beef jerky i don't know how to voice that yeah i thought my game crashed no i thought it broke as long as i'm fit to fly in your eyes on you means I have only one more eval left to do.
He acts as if I do these things for fun.
Then I have to make a report with things like I have found myself...
Ah-ha!
I think I've seen like the like screenshot or whatever of this.
I have found myself sexually excited at the sight of cartoon horses.
Jimmy's a brony.
Well, I could take it off your hands.
I've known him a long time.
He won't try any bullshit with me.
Voice him like macho man Randy Savage.
I suppose you are the captain.
I am the captain.
Thank you.
What a relief.
Requesting permission to clip out of context, sir.
There's worse things in me out there.
Go ahead.
Oh, before I forget, Swansea asked me to give you this.
They can't expect me to perform miracles.
Not sure what it means, but sounds like fun.
Good luck, Captain.
I'm curly!
Talk to Jimmy and Swansea.
Thaiske described his experience as intern so far as, Super cool and, like, totally awesome.
Like, awesome.
Should I be worried?
What a beautiful day it is.
Swansea and Daisuke have been fixing this broken vent for days.
Best to stay away.
All the pills.
Little does he know.
This will be his meal.
We are here for you.
anxiety you are enough all feelings are okay you are valid not all thoughts are true you are not alone you will be alright this feeling will pass you are not a burden this does not define you everybody loves clean what are these What is this one?
Oh, it's like another anxiety thing.
I like the Polaroids.
They're cute.
Everybody loves clean.
This is gonna be your bed.
Wait, this is...
Scary.
I've been bringing the same playlist along for years.
When it's right, it's right.
So true?
Alright, Swansean.
Jimmy.
Sorry, I had to stop myself from calling him Johnny.
Whoa!
A trucker's kind of meals.
Kind of fast, kind of cheap, kind of edible.
Wait, you have to pay for these?
You're on company...
You are away on company work and you pay for your food?
This thing's been out of coffee for over a month.
It's for the best.
The caffeine keeps me up anyway.
Work makes the dream work.
Yay!
He should have said nay!
Teamwork makes the dream work!
Alright, let's go find some guys.
Um, what's over here?
Since we didn't get to...
Oh, the door to my quarters!
I'm still on the clock though.
Ah, where does everyone else sleep?
What if you need to party?
Hmm.
Ney is like no though But Ney is
This is Big Head Jimmy right here Okay buddy We'll come back to you What happened Oh my god Daisuke
Well I can see the issue The kid was brought on just to make me suffer.
Interned my ass.
I was just trying to fix the vent.
How did that trigger the emergency foe?
Because you're talented in all the wrong ways.
I would have dealt with this, but only you could unlock the axe case.
Every goddamn thing has to go through you.
Oh, okay.
I'm the captain.
It's so we don't have craziness on board.
I'll handle it.
Hang in there, Daisuke.
It looks really comfy.
Put me in the foam, Caton.
Do not touch.
What's this thing?
Seems like Swansea is teaching Daisuke the basics.
He's got a long way to go.
The music's kind of...
What are these?
Oh, emergency cryogenic pods.
They have about 20 years of backup power.
Oh.
Oh, this is the utility room.
Wait, before we get the axe, let's talk to this guy.
Then Pony Express said they don't provide on-board entertainment.
Feels like there's always something broken in that room.
Tollpar's starting to show her age.
Pass inspection, right?
Shouldn't be an issue.
Plus they added die scale last minute.
Sorry, didn't it count there'd be five of us now?
I really should have made a bigger stink about that.
Oh no!
Daisuke!
Uh, oh.
My code scanner!
I can't read it.
Uh, two six zero nine.
This is cool, I like this part.
Two, six, zero, nine.
Take axe.
Here's Jimmy.
Oh, wait.
Do I need to use axe?
Okay, I'll be careful.
Watch your toes.
Oh, my God.
Hi, Rees!
Ouch!
Oof.
Strong stuff, huh?
Get it through your goddamn skull.
That vent is strictly off-limits.
Fully effing collapsed inside.
You looking to get impaled, electrocuted, and cooked?
Yeah, but like, you can't fit in there to fix it, right?
Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot.
So I can totally handle it.
Captain, give me the axe.
Swansea, this could have damaged the pods.
Gurren, welcome back.
Thank you.
You can't let something like this happen again.
Yeah, yeah.
I got it.
Loud and clear.
Keep the axe until you've cleaned this all up, yeah?
Wait, so, but don't we want to not clean up the foam?
Because that means that there's...
hole those loose electrical wires are a hazard in itself especially with dice get around
um yes jimmy can i help you this is before the crash yeah i know but like isn't that still what they are meant what the foam is meant to do
I take it, Anya, diagnosed you with being sane, then?
Just off-center, but it's what keeps me on my toes.
I said I'd do yours.
I want to hear all about those cartoon horses.
Is that something you were born with or a recent developer?
All right, all right, shut up.
Let's go to the cockpit.
Yes, sir.
I mean, I'm the sir.
sir yeah wait where was the cockpit was it down this way were you born this freaky or is it a recent development there's a what was it there's like a new I never played puppet combo games before but there's a new one that just came out and it's called like skin freak or something I was like this is made for me I I was born,
freaky died, freaky.
Born in the afterlife, freaky.
Whoa, wait.
This is not the cockpit.
Wait, what's going on?
Wait, what's happening?
It all started when they released this game called Umamusume.
The music stopped.
Oh my, wow!
That's pretty steep.
Oh.
Oh, do I have a flashlight?
Jimmy?
Uh, Anya, I think you misdiagnosed me.
Sane?
Oh.
Whoa.
Aurora Borealis.
Oh.
Okay, now it's spooky.
Wait.
Wait, I don't like it anymore.
What?
I don't like it anymore.
Why?
Oh.
Fell to the end of Ava, right?
Big staircase.
You're supposed to insert your own music.
Umapioi!
No, umapioi!
Oh, we're having vision.
Visions.
Are we, like, going back to how curly is in present day?
Where's the horse?
Oh, whoa.
Did it say?
Where's the horse?
Oh, whoa.
I don't understand the ladders that keep popping up.
Ah!
Oh, no!
Oh!
Oh, I can't look away!
Ah!
My eyes!
Is that a door?
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Oh, my eyes!
Oh.
Ah.
Whoa.
Jimmy, what kind of renovations did you do to this place?
Jimmy bet me 50 credits this thing will never see the outside.
out of this locker.
So far, he's winning.
There's the key.
I need to leave this here just in case.
Did we not want to do it?
Wait.
739.
But where do I put it in?
Oh.
Not sure this geriatric thing would be any use in a real emergency.
swans, swears they're more reliable than anything made this deck in.
Ha.
Okay.
Hello, Jimbo?
You can't just make something up for this?
It's not like these evals ever go anywhere when we get back.
We'll power through it.
Have you been able to complete your mandated tasks as co-pilot efficiently and to your fullest capacity?
Oh, well.
Let's see.
Okay.
I'll just put good for that one.
That's all of them.
Done and done.
How were things otherwise?
Off the record.
I like it.
We're in control here.
That's weird.
That's a weird thing to say.
Didn't think you'd ever take to being a freighter pilot as well as you have.
With how you struggle back on Earth.
Sure.
All I ever hear is how great of a leader you are.
Jimmy...
Freighter?
What did I say?
Oh!
Freighter.
Sorry.
Jimmy's so jealous.
I don't!
Honestly, it's kind of annoying.
Okay.
What?
Why is it annoying?
sorry i'm starting to give him like a dice gay accent so what is it hmm how come it always always seems like you're standing on the edge of a bridge with your feet in cement lately i've just been thinking is this enough should i just stay here because i've been successful at it a good long haul freighter captain and that's bad that's what i'm i'm saying it's not but it's terrifying i think am i figured out is this all i'll ever be or do i take the risk and try something new even if i'm bad at it i get it though change is scary especially if you're comfortable you know i guess i get it you reach the highest rung on this ladder
So now you're thinking you might be on the wrong ladder altogether.
Still, a long way, uh, still a long way down from the top no matter how you look at it.
While I'm still climbing and climbing.
Something like that.
But hey, hey, hey, you know I believe in you.
Here.
On earth.
Doesn't matter.
Oh, here, on earth.
Yeah, it doesn't matter where.
Aww.
Ha.
You should write that on a site, on the psych eval.
Message incoming!
Oh no, the big guys themselves.
Hay is for horses.
Sorry.
That was me trying to nay.
I don't think I'm having, I don't think I've cut out for being a horse girl.
Guess that's my cue.
I'll see you later.
Okay, bye.
What are they asking for?
Oh, take news from corporate.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, no!
Wait, what's it say?
Take, take what?
Wait, oh, why?
Why is it so dark?
I can't see anything.
This flashlight is dukey.
Okay, let's just go forward.
Curly has really changed ever since he left Mo and Larry!
Wait, this...
This is kind of spooky.
Take your beds, yeah!
Why is it red?
And then failed her audition to become a cartoon horse.
I sure did.
Love cartoons!
Whoa, hello nurse!
We're all starting to get a thing for worse.
What are you talking about?
It was the worst impression ever.
Oh my gosh.
This is what they mean when they say so many fish in the sea.
They're all on the beach.
Wait.
Wait, did it just loop?
I think it just looped.
Turn it back down just in case there's a jump scare.
has jump scares or not it feels like the beginning of mgs4 where i'm watching the different tv channels
whoa time for me to go eat some cake since my birthday marco happy birthday what is this i don't like it
whoa what's it called is
on tv oh that's my channel spooky scary skeletons and shivers up your spine oh you
know when spongebob's watching that like that like channel where it's got like the the dancing dancing of anemone and gary comes in he's like gary I wasn't watching anything.
That's what I feel like watching this channel is like where you're just like...
You're like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're getting a little, we're getting a little heated in here.
A revolutionary new dental hygiene product.
Wait, is this the mouthwash?
Brand new formula designed to kill bacteria and kill germs without leaving a bad taste.
Dragon breath.
Mouthwash.
All day, fire fresh.
My game is broken again.
Two months after the crash.
It's...
This is...
Mouthwash?
Unfreaking believable.
There's gotta be an...
ocean of the stuff in here.
No way!
It's all mouthwash!
This room looks freaking endless.
This is what they'd have five people hauling for over a year.
All of this?
For mouthwash?
The sugar content probably offsets any potential as disinfectant.
Disinfectant.
What are you...
Let me see that.
What are you checking?
14% ethanol.
Ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
What?
I suppose we'll smell good at least.
That's right, kiddo.
You can bet your ass on that.
What are you doing?
Stop that!
Wait, why is he drinking it?
It's basically booze.
Oh.
I thought ethanol was like gasoline.
Woo!
Oh, shut up.
They do put it in gas.
Oh, okay.
It's alcohol.
Pure alcohol.
Uh-oh.
That's not good.
I'm just an old...
Codger?
Taking care of his dental hygiene.
You hear that?
That's the sound of 15 years of sobriety popping like a siss.
Wait, so...
So if you wanted to...
If you wanted to clean your mouth, if you...
If you actually washed it out with, like...
I don't know...
Vodgons?
Does that work?
You could do that.
But I guess because of the sugar, it wouldn't work as like a disinfectant, like she said.
You could.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
Oh, I'm learning.
It would kill the bacteria.
Wow.
You could as long as you don't swap.
okay that's I've I've never had vodka I thought it never had a taste because it's clear I don't know what it tastes like
it burns tastes like burning what it's
It's not good.
It's fire fresh.
A glorious magnificent red hot cyst.
Good riddance and cheers.
Why did my kid say he's turning into a pirate?
To Captain Curly.
Here here.
Guess anyone could get seriously blasted off of this stuff.
Yeah, and kill you in the process.
This can't be real.
I, there's no way.
Now we go out in style.
Arrg.
Dysky.
Come here, me boy.
I can't even remember how I talk.
Anyone ever teach you how to drink like a man?
Oh, no.
This is so...
Oh, I think we're transitioning somewhere.
Oh, yeah.
Six days before the crash.
Who...
Break the news.
I need to tell them.
News from corporate.
After all these years, just like that.
Wait, what?
What?
Mr. Krabs, when did you get in this game?
We're breaking the news.
Are they firing all of us?
Surprise!
Look at your face.
Read the note, it wouldn't let me.
You ever got so drunk?
you turn into a pirate all it took was that guy one one sippy gotcha
jeez uh wow uh what's the occasion we only get one communal birthday party per trip right so we can have it whenever only one person can really be surprise birthday per trip.
We did Swansea last haul, remember?
No way, I can't believe I missed that.
You were next on the list, so congratulations.
Hate to say it though, your duties have to extend to even your own birthday party.
You're the only one with clearance to make the cake.
The recipe is there by the machine.
Hop to it, Captain.
Wait, I am making the cake now.
Break a cake.
The music's so cute.
Wait.
I can't.
It won't let me read the note.
I don't think.
Yeah, I keep clicking and it's not letting me.
Wow.
So cute.
Oh.
Everybody.
That's a really big knife.
Holy moly.
Oh, we have a spaghetti.
What do we need this knife for?
Gemma.
Sorry for jumping you.
This whole thing is corny.
But you know, it's kind of a tradition now.
Okay, it's not corny.
It's sweet.
I dare say I almost look forward to it.
Hmm?
Nothing.
Yeah, no, I agree.
Oh, I think we're...
We've been sacked.
Did you just say Mondays aren't the best, but coworkers can make it better?
The music is so cute.
Yeah, I was going to say, or worse, like, way worse.
You're going to use the Pony Express provided cake recipe?
At least make it correctly.
You should find the ingredients and recipe in the kitchen.
Swansea really likes that cake.
Don't tell anyone.
Humph.
He's so too nitted.
Hmm, I think you need to use the code scanner.
They're really getting a lot of mileage out of that thing, huh?
You know how it is.
Pony Express being either cheap or lazy.
Usually both, no?
Okay.
Oh, what about you, Daisuke?
What do you have to say?
Could you sneak an extra packet of sweetener in there?
Just kidding.
Maybe?
Nah, totally kidding.
Unless?
It's been dead I pirate.
More likely than you think.
Okay, wait, that's a Campbell soup.
What is this thing for?
Okay, hold on.
Alright, we read this earlier.
We're professionals already.
We mix water and gelatin.
Water, take, and gelatin, doko.
And also, where do we mix it?
Eh?
Yeah.
Uh.
Hold on, everybody.
I'm the captain.
Those balloons are hard.
Check the recipe again.
What did I miss?
It says I need the scanner, but I don't see where.
Oh, here!
Here, here!
Ah!
Oh, I see!
Wait, but gelatin doesn't... Oh, 4213.
Where do I put in the code, though?
Not now.
Okay, my bad.
Oh, there's bird sounds.
Is this not a window?
Oh, I thought...
I thought this whole time it was a window.
Um...
I like how sweetener is, like, behind me.
Where do I get the...
Gelatin?
Cake base plus sweetener.
There's also no thing for cake base.
Unless it's...
This becomes the cake base.
Wait.
Oh!
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
What was it again?
I didn't realize there was numbers.
4, 2, 1, 3.
Okay.
Whoa, I thought this was a pancake maker.
All right.
Joseph, use.
Water, use.
Okay.
Whoa, okay.
And then we need you.
Two, three, four, one.
2-3-4-1, 2-3-4-1, 2-3-4-1, 2-3-4-1
Yes, take the sweetener!
Um...
Wait, uh, where should I use it?
Wait, maybe here, again?
Ah, okay, okay.
Sweetener?
Mix!
Throw in some extra sweetener?
Whoa.
That's so cute!
What else?
Oh, that's it.
Yay!
Yay, yay!
It wouldn't let me do an extra pack, though, because we could only...
Right?
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
I want to make the drink.
Oh!
Gosh.
They're so fast.
You gotta make a speech.
Can't argue with that.
Speech, speech, speech, speech.
Go on.
I...
Hey, what's wrong?
Uh-oh.
He's breaking the news.
That's all I said on the report from management.
We will receive the paycheck for this delivery.
I don't know any more than that.
Pony Express finally kicking the bucket, huh?
What a joke.
and we're the punchline.
I don't have any savings.
Anya, no!
Anya!
Oh my god.
Come live with me, baby girl.
They can't just do this, right?
Pony Express was one of the last man crew.
Pony Express, sorry, freighter companies.
The writing's been on the wall for a long time.
When did they tell you?
earlier this week I was instructed to wait until we're closer to the hall destination but I can't keep something like this from you all so I guess you got what you wanted don't say that Jimmy yeah without the guilt ah Jim Jim if I had known I can go back to my,
how'd you put it?
Struggle of a life.
Anya never got into medical school because she's, well, let's be real.
What is that supposed to mean?
And how many employment years?
Swansea got left in them.
Daisuke will be fine.
Mommy and daddy have him covered.
So there's that at least.
But you?
Headed for bigger and better, right?
Oh my god, it's not my fault that the company is shutting down!
Chill!
I'm just...
It's not like I got a promotion.
I'm getting fired, too.
I'm just working on my life being a place I don't have to freaking escape.
That's what I was trying to tell you.
Nothing more.
We're the ones you're trying to escape.
Leave the dirt behind now that your boots are clean.
That's not what I meant.
It is what you meant.
You just couldn't frame it.
to yourself in a way that kept you as the hero.
A fan in the crew but remain the model captain.
What am I supposed to do?
Um...
Oh!
Let's have some freaking cake, hmm?
Props to the Twilight Cruise of the Topar.
Props to our captain and his new prospects.
What?
I don't understand why Jimmy's being this way.
It's not like we are... I'm like a CEO or something.
I don't get it.
Uh...
Nobody's talking to me.
He must be fun at parties.
Wait, this is literally it.
Um...
Oh, take the knife.
Uh-oh.
But this is before the crash, though.
A large kitchen knife.
Regulations say I should keep it locked up behind the scanner.
Oh!
Okay!
Who's hungry?
Where's some cake?
Oh.
This is a bizarre way to cut a cake.
I'm sawing it like a tree.
Oh, uh-oh.
Three months after the crash.
Who's talking?
Someone's yelling.
Check on Curly.
Uh-oh.
Did I escape?
He's still asleep.
Oh my gosh.
Polly says.
Are you working hard?
We're hardly working.
Hee-hee.
Oh my gosh, there's mouthwash bottles everywhere.
Oh!
Oh my god, wait, the food!
These rations have to last us a long time.
We just need to have discipline.
Uncertified hamster, thank you so much for the vibe.
Good to thank you!
It's a knife that bludgeoned the cake that hard.
I'm right!
Wait, it's broken.
Oh my god, look.
Oh, find Daisuke's employee card.
Looks like his name is Daisy.
Employee card, Daisuke.
There's so many bottles oh my gosh they're literally everywhere even behind the plant why
oh this doesn't he guys i don't think this is so good maybe she's with curly wait if where's i thought this was gonna be swan's bed where does he sleep then
Oh my gosh.
Anybody?
Oh, I can't even make the cake.
The thing is all foamed.
And the suffering.
Thank you so much for the dead gifted.
Oh my goodness.
Thank you.
Oh, this is... Oh, I didn't realize this was a bed.
He keeps sleeping outside utility.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
For some reason, I only saw the boss.
I didn't see anything else.
Are you making all that noise?
Oh, oh gosh, this is so horrible.
Just become a ghost like me.
I don't know if he's been given his medicine yet.
Find Anya.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Just a handful left.
Once these are out, we'll have nothing to keep him quiet.
Keep him quiet.
Oh, my gosh.
Anya!
Give him the peels?
But we have to find Anya first.
Oh, my God.
He's just, like, crying.
You can hear him throughout the whole ship.
god it's like a haunting like
you hear him in the vents oh my god oh my god the soul good thing we have so many more bottles we'll never go we'll never we'll never go hungry
ania ania I'm scared Wait, uh, maybe utility?
Swansea hasn't let anyone since the crash.
It says it's filled with foam.
Maybe the cockpit?
There's only so many rooms you can go in.
Oh my god, oh, you can...
Oh, okay.
Hello!
No, I understand completely.
If that's how it has to be.
Oh!
Oh, it's you.
Jimmy, not able to sleep either.
It's night time.
Why are you talking this late?
Anya, are you crying?
No, don't worry.
I'm okay.
We all need to keep it together.
Oh, I'm keeping it together.
Don't you worry, Captain.
He's making noises again.
meds before, Anya?
Uh, no.
It must have slipped my mind.
I'm sorry, I'll...
I'll do it.
No, really.
I'm perfectly okay.
I said I'll do it.
Give Curly painkillers.
Okay.
Well, if I take this rope, that means Curly owes us 50 bucks.
Right?
That was their bet, no?
okay let's go this way I don't know which way is fastest oh my god I just don't want to hear him anymore it's so oh it's so horrible how could you sleep through this
oh my gosh oh my gosh okay I don't think it's so much for the hunk of simp but here's some random voice lines from an old movie if you can guess hey this astronaut food isn't too bad that's toothpaste carl oh minty what is it from
take painkiller give to oh oops oh uh
open wide oh my god oh my god God!
Come on, stop with the noise.
Okay, can you blame him?
Damn it.
I know what everyone is thinking.
The way they look at me.
Wait, what?
What could I even say?
And then...
Okay, what would she do?
Alright, Jimmy.
Give the poor man his meds, please.
Damn it!
Here we are now.
Me and the driver's seat.
Thanks for that.
Open up.
I hope these make you feel free.
You know,
I struggle taking pills too.
Do I just need to get punched in the stomach for it to work?
Dang, those meds work fast.
Why?
Why did you beat him up, Jimmy?
Oh my gosh.
No one saw that, right?
We're the worst!
He feels everything probably like 50 times more because he's just muscle!
He has no skin!
Actually, if this happens to someone, they can't grow the skin back, right?
Jimmy deserves a slap.
Like...
Why are humans so inefficient?
They can't grow their skin back.
They need skin grafts.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's right.
You'd think after three months, at least a little skin would grow.
You'd think he would, like, scab over, right?
Yeah, he should be one big scab now.
Probably.
Gotta use the secret family technique of wrapping the pill in cheese.
Yes, the ancient technique passed down from generation to generation.
All right, bye, Curly.
Oh, just kidding.
Why doesn't Curly grow his skin back?
Is he lazy?
Oh, take what?
Oh, it's my thumbnail.
Curly, you're up.
Oh, everything is...
Mouth?
I was going to say everything is foamed, but no, everything is mouthed.
Mouthwash!
Polly.
Everything is mouthwash!
Oh, take responsibility.
Is that what it said?
I couldn't read it.
Oh.
Why is it just curly?
We should have some.
Why?
It's mediocre at best, obviously.
Jimmy is such a...
Downer.
This game is a great object lesson and when you should stop projecting yourself on a protagonist.
That's so true!
Sometimes you can only get the subpar stuff.
That's what makes the really good stuff, well, good.
Right?
Why bother?
Hey.
We all tried to escape.
Just borrow Jimmy's skin suit.
This is what VTubers look like when they take off their skin suits.
Like, you know how Doki has skin suits?
This is what she looks like underneath.
Didn't work for any of us.
I've thought many times, is this what peace feels like?
Is it good enough?
Oh, these like cinematic angles.
If I'm being real, it certainly isn't the best.
So all I can do is try and make my life one I'm not trying to run from all the time.
Sometimes I'll be promoted, buy a house, fall in love, but other times, I'll just have some awful freaking cake with my friend.
Curly's a tomato?
I mean, look at it.
Right now, that sounds pretty brilliant, yeah?
So if you'll do the honors?
Right.
Well, let me go find a knife.
Find a knife why is it why is it red why is it red so spooky find a knife where i walked around i didn't see one oh maybe they're here oh oh i
can't see barely anything i feel like i'm gonna get jump scared by a horse where are we going
It's so dark, yeah.
I can't see anything.
Oh, wait.
What?
Is that a body?
No, okay.
It's mouthwash.
This part's kind of spooky.
In the cockpit?
Oh, that's right.
It said it's with the stuff, right?
That the knife was supposed to be locked up in the cockpit.
Oh!
That's...
Oh, um, oh, it won't, uh, it won't let me grab anything else.
I think that's a little bit dramatic for a cake, no?
Feast!
Uh, bon appetit?
Oh, what's happening?
Oh, I'm scared.
Wait, I'm lost?
Wait, I can't say anything.
Eh, I'll just keep running.
Forward, uh, wait, where's the...
Where's the door?
Oh, here?
Wait, eh?
I can't move.
Oh, there we go.
It's so dark.
Oh, my goodness.
Why is the music?
What's happening?
I'm just going to keep running.
I feel like I'm getting chased or something.
Oh, oh, no, wait.
We were joking about the jerky, Jimmy.
Oh, Jimmy.
Jimmy, it was just a...
It was just a little joke, Jimmy!
It was a playful!
No, this isn't actually happening, right?
No, no way.
Oh, no, no, no!
Okay, good.
I didn't have to do anything.
Okay, it was all in our head.
It was all...
Check on the crew, four months after the crash.
Oh my god!
Die scared!
What's happening to you?
man can't, he can't hold his mouth wash.
Andrew, welcome to Babusha.
Thank you.
How many have you had?
Those will kill you before before anything else.
I know.
My mom found this internship for me.
Such a slacker, she said.
I don't know.
I just never knew what I wanted to be.
Never was good at anything.
Aww.
He's just a kid.
Total screw up.
We're not done yet, Daisuke.
I just hope she doesn't blame herself.
Aww.
Oh, he was so...
Please, just take it.
He was so optimistic months ago.
I don't want to look at this stuff anymore.
I'll take it for you, buddy.
Aww.
It's so sad.
Oh, uh, this is a cockpit.
Can we go into utility?
No.
It says it's filled with foam.
I don't believe that.
I don't believe that at all.
Yeah, dice can become a streamer.
It's what all people do who don't know what they want to do.
Wait, did I miss a door?
Oh, yeah, there we go.
Anya?
Miss Anya?
Oh, he says...
A kiss, you have to thank you for the gift.
I didn't see, I didn't get to see who braided, but thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, welcome in, everybody.
That was...
Polly said...
Look at Swansea, go, baby.
Okay, shut up, Polly.
We don't need to know what you say all the time.
Anya.
Ah!
Oh, it startled me.
sorry no worries you thinking about drinking that too honestly yeah it'd probably just make me feel sick wouldn't fix anything as much as I'd like it to right hey I was thinking lucky thank you for the gifted did you know that not all the medicine aboard was in my office we store some in a storage locker in the hallway why haven't you brought this up earlier it was foamed up I didn't think it was possible to reach it but I've been estimating the position of the foam I think the medicine depot locker isn't too far into the mass of it so we could try to break it down one strike too many on a weak spot well I'll get sucked into space I mean is that so much worse than the situation you're in now Is anyone even coming to get you guys?
I think it's worth the risk.
If nothing else, it's an excuse to get Swansea to hand over the axe.
Break the foam.
Oh, that's what he's holding.
I thought it was a cane.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no, this is real.
Hey, Swansea.
Hey there, buddy.
He's doing the...
The robot.
Jumbo.
El Capitano.
The man with the plan.
You done?
I need that.
This old thing?
This was entrusted to me by our previous, tragically inclined leader.
Best...
Oh, sorry.
Big...
Res...
Resp...
responsibility but you know all about that huh I'm going to try and get some more painkillers I can't help but schmoof with him it's kind of it's kind of addicting he's got he's doing the divorced man wiggle
he's got that mouth washing gut now do something useful you know oh I heard all about it you're looking to pull the plug on this party early i'm trying to save us take matters into your own hands i be my guest what beautiful eyes you have so antsy wait not the window wait it's starting to look more and more like these like weird vision worlds we go to
i just realized with poly down and now the axe and everything You can still hear the seagulls.
You good, buddy?
I think I already feel the ship rumble tumbling through space again.
Ha!
Back to the future!
I think he's...
He's just taken a little...
He's been partying.
Way too hardy.
Oh!
So, Anci.
Employee card.
Oh, all we need is...
Well, actually, we only got one of them.
No, we only got one of them.
have two of them.
We need Anya and...
Okay, Anya.
Where's the phone?
Where's that phone?
Anya, where's the phone?
See the phone by the hallway to medical?
You can kind of see the locker in there.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
He's all thumbed out.
Don't say that.
Not this one.
Uh...
Oh my gosh, we have no more meds.
That's for you, Curly.
How you doing, buddy?
Oh, sorry.
He's like Pavlovd in the open in his mouth once he sees me.
I guess let me get the axe out.
Can I use this thing here?
Oh, here we go.
Ah, there, there, there.
Oh, yes I can.
There we go.
Ha, yeah!
Oh, I think you can get it now.
Heya!
Oops.
What's...
Take the painkillers!
Isopropyl alcohol!
McMac, thank you so much for the vibe, gifted.
We're gonna go give it to him.
I'll go tell Anya.
Just kidding.
Uh.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
She's a ghost.
Oh, wow, Jim.
You did it.
Yeah.
It actually wasn't that hard once.
I figured...
it out amazing really sure okay take the compliment buddy um i hate to ask you again but could you give curly his painkillers it still just just makes me so nauseous you're not serious look i've entertained your sentimentality up until now but i'm trying to actually fix things on you oh my gosh what what is giving curly his painkillers Taking you away from,
huh?
I'm getting us through this.
I...
Wait, what did it say?
It's find the code scanner.
Then figure out the door code.
Get the axe.
Oh, chop up the foam, but not too much.
Yeah, I said take responsibility.
If so, Ava.
And best of all, give Curly his freaking medicine.
I have to.
Because the captain has to take the freaking responsibility on this goddamn ship!
Freaking.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to.
Go make sure Daisuke doesn't choke on his own vomit.
No, no, I can't.
I'll take care of it, Anya.
Oh, now you're gonna be nice about it.
Freaking, freak.
Your actions have consequences.
I always do.
Bottoms up, curly.
He's already opening wide.
No, we're going to give the painkillers.
Wait, what?
Oh my god, wait.
We're going to give him the painkillers.
We have three.
That's mad.
I was wondering what the isopropyl alcohol is for.
No, that's messed up.
But what would Jimmy do?
Okay, I'll give him medicine.
I don't think I understood the pressure you were under before.
And you tried to tell me.
Our worst moments don't make us monsters, huh?
You were a good captain, Curly.
And you'll be one again.
I'll get us both through this.
Jimmy Redemption Arc?
He just yelled at Anya.
Jimmy would give the alcohol this one, see?
Who's crying?
Curly, don't cry.
What is Curly?
What could he even be thinking at this moment?
You know?
The redemption ship is long sailed.
I agree.
Oh.
Six hours until judgment?
Wait, what is...
Jimmy, get the fuck out here!
Wait, what's happening?
What's going on?
Uh...
What's this?
The rope?
Take the rope?
You can't hide!
Uh...
Take the metal pipe?
I'm gonna chop you into 20 fucking faces!
Uh...
Where do I...
Part of a metal pipe that broke off in the crash.
Still strong enough to be repurposed.
Wait, what is this?
My hands won't stop shaking.
What is that?
It's like...
What is...
A length of strong nylon rope I could use this?
For what?
What exactly are we using it for?
The metal pipe?
Huh?
Two days before the crash.
What?
What is my judgment?
What is happening?
Not my judgment.
Jimmy's judgment.
You doing okay?
Said Curly.
Yeah, can't sleep.
I know how that is.
I just toss and turn.
Wow, it's so cute that it makes like a night sky and everything.
Or stare at the ceiling all night.
actually kind of like the nighttime window screen if you can believe it so I just come look at it sometimes if you could look really really close you can see there's a dead pixel in the upper right corner that's called a star on you that's so nope don't see it in the back of my mind it's always there now I'll go bonkers looking for it cheers I don't think it ruins the illusion though it's peaceful but maybe I'm just used to looking at the bigger picture how many days of transport do we have left let's see off the top of my head around two hundred and thirty seven days that's right said that at the beginning huh just under eight months hey why do you think pony Express put a lock on the medical room door but not in the sleeping
quarters hmm I suppose it's for the same reason they put a lock on the cockpit
but doesn't everyone sleep in the sleeping quarters right
yeah I feel like lock on that people can't just take the medicine and stuff.
They have their own rooms.
Hey!
Safety.
Oh, safety.
Just remember how to get the Neverland first 10 pixel to the right.
Straight on till morning.
Ah.
Five months after the crash.
Oh.
Wait.
Jimmy, help!
Oh?
What's wrong?
Jimmy, it's a total emergency!
Calm down, what is it?
Anya is stuck in medical.
The door won't open.
What if she runs out of something?
Right.
Let's go have a look.
Wait, what do you mean something?
Anya?
What do you got?
M-Mikan.
Yes.
Hey, heard the locks broken.
Hey, Anya!
Can you hear me?
Yeah, I can hear you, Jimmy.
The rest of our medicine stash is in there too.
Damn, this could be bad.
Did you try to really...
Did you try to really put your...
back into it?
Any wrenches lying around?
How heavy is the med kit?
What if she is not locked in there?
What if she locked you guys out?
Anya, is the door stuck?
No.
Huh?
What do you mean?
Look, we're all stressed, but you can't go breaking down at every little hardship.
Okay.
Open the damn door.
You were right.
You were right all along.
I should have done this from the beginning.
Oh no.
I always believed that our worst moments didn't define us.
Didn't make us be on repair.
You think I wanted this either?
Make no mistake, this isn't my worst moment.
Far from it.
It's the best decision I'll ever make.
Open the door.
I'll take care of it.
Anya!
What does that mean?
Curly is still in there with her, right?
Yeah.
You don't think?
Dyskate.
You and Swansea know the internals of the ship better than anyone.
There's absolutely no other way into medical.
Uh, well, Swansea said it was strictly off-limits.
Like super mega not allowed above all else.
The utility room.
That busted vent in there loops into medical.
But I mean, technically a person could totally fit through it.
If that's the only way, we'll make it work.
You listening on ya?
Five.
Come on, dice game.
Oh, no, oh, no, no.
Wait, but that's...
Oh, oh, no.
Oh, no.
Um.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
Just want to look in here real quick.
It's kind of crazy.
That this is all mouthwash.
That's kind of insane.
Actually...
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
Gosh, man.
Oh, man.
I don't like this at all.
What could Anya be thinking?
We should go check out utility, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, where is Swansea?
Oh, speak at the devil.
Hello, Master.
Swansea, we need your help.
I know you said utility was dangerous, but I...
I'm good right here, fellas.
You know, I'm not letting you in there.
Off limits.
Look, if there's any possibility, Jimbo.
He looks so bad.
He looks even more like a thumb than before.
Letting you scratch off that foam wall would be useless.
You'd only tear this goddamn ship a new asshole.
Nothing to be done about it.
Bad luck.
Tail missed the donkey.
What?
Huh?
I've never heard that phrase before.
for.
But Swansea, this could be really bad.
Just hear us out.
We're God's hand-picked favorites on this here planet, I reckon.
Pin the tail on the donkey.
Oh!
Yes, yes, yes.
Means we get to name it.
So let's hear it for Wake Rock.
Whatever's going on anywhere else ain't my problem.
Since I'm the happiest man Wake Rock has ever seen.
Oh my god, these voices are starting to kill my throat, though, guys.
I'm taking a...
I'm just gonna speak normal for a bit.
I can't...
I can't be a man.
Let's just go, Daisuke.
There's no point with him.
Oh, just kidding.
The jumps are getting, like, more and more sporadic.
Whoa, what is this?
Eight hours until judgment.
Don't do anything.
Stop, stop.
I can fix this.
Why do you keep fucking saying that?
Are you hearing yourself?
Wait, what happened?
Daisuke!
I'm so sorry.
Oh, he didn't say he's so sorry.
He's just sorry.
We still have disinfectant.
Oh, I said I was going to stop, but I kept doing it.
We still have disinfectant, right?
The one from the extra medical stash?
Get it.
Now!
Oh, yeah, I did it.
use it the cocktail we you the cocktail what are you blabbering about what was your fault you would never have I had no choice wait what you useless you goddamn fucking idiot there has to be something else wait he made what did he make like a drink or something?
Buying disinfectant.
Uh, oh, uh, uh, uh, um, uh, uh, uh, mouthwash?
Uh.
You'll be okay.
You'll be okay, you'll be okay, daiski!
Uh.
Let's go back.
There's nothing else in here, right?
No, okay.
Something in medical?
Oh, we could...
Whoa.
Whoa!
What?
I'm already looking in here.
At least try to make yourself useful.
God damn it!
Oh, geez.
Okay, sorry.
My bad.
Whoa!
Something.
All the lights are out, too.
Like, it looks like just...
Emergency lights are on?
What the?
Who?
What does that say?
SD?
Oh, wait.
Oh.
I'm stupid.
Whoa.
We're in a bit of a hurry, so let's run.
Wait, what do you mean?
here we go.
What do you guys mean?
What's happening?
Oh!
Take responsibility.
Oh.
Okay.
Ooh.
There's a lot of blood.
Okay.
Whoa.
Uh.
Did that just say Polly says?
Okay.
Polly.
he says is this spelling something out on the stairs i can't tell be quiet is that what it just said
oh oh
should i not move
i can't oh my gosh wait is there actually a poly monster
i want to know what this notepad says
Oh my god.
A blind beast, aimless and restless.
You can't run from it.
Okay.
I can't even tell where it's from.
Where it's at.
Okay, I'm just trucking along.
If I walk, I make noise.
Is that him or me?
I can't tell that's me.
Oh my god.
What if I die?
Ah!
Stop with your heavy feet, Jimmy!
Oh my god.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
I didn't see anything, though.
Can I only see it with the scanner?
How the hell am I supposed to get out of here?
I think he is right in front of me.
Oh my god.
There's so many sounds from everywhere.
Okay, I'm going to try going.
Am I following, like, the blood or something?
Oh!
Oh, that's it.
Oh, there was something there.
I'm going to try following the blood.
Brandon, thank you so much for the...
Thank you, thank you!
If he comes close...
Where is it?
Wait, what is this?
Can I not go this way?
if i don't look at it i can't see that there's no there's a wall there he is oh i think i saw his nostril oh this really is a wall no no way okay um
oh my god can you kind of see him that's crazy wait oh maybe i should have zoomed in haunts If I walk, am I okay?
Or, like, because I'm still making a sound.
I guess we'll find out.
I'm making a lot of noise, though.
I'm making so much noise.
I'm scared.
Where is he?
Oh, I think I died.
Okay, so walking...
Does alert him?
My god!
He's right there.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Keep going.
I don't know where he's gotta go.
Seems kind of far.
Now he's closer.
Okay.
Peter, the horse is here.
That does not look like a way.
But it looks like there...
What if there's, like, a secret down there?
Oh my god.
There was no secret.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, oh, sorry, sorry.
Okay, don't worry about it.
You just gotta be careful about him getting too close and...
I want to pet his horse nose.
I don't...
I think I saw that, like, it dips down over there, so I don't feel like I go there.
Hello?
maybe this way
seems kind of far okay he's close I wish the what's it called we're better on this the light so I could see it better
yes yes Polly says it's
pretty forgiving though hopefully it's not three strikes you're out you know Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh.
Here's four.
We did it!
Ah, okay.
Mouthwash time!
Bad breath ain't nothing but a dream.
You're right, it's here, poor princess.
I'm sorry.
I messed up.
Don't try to talk.
Drink this.
Goop, goop, goop, goop, goop, goop.
Goop, goop.
Did we just dump it all over him?
Oh my gosh, when everyone stops, starts dying, you can just, you can just start dumping mouthwash on them to make the corpses not smell so bad.
I think the vent and utility connects to medical.
But you heard what he said going in there now.
It's too unstable.
Trying to break the foam could risk the air seal.
I just don't want to screw up again like I did before.
You heard Anya.
I wouldn't put it past her to do something extreme right now.
You want me, Daisuke?
We can save Curly, yeah?
Oh, now?
Okay, Jimmy.
Now you care about Curly?
Okay.
Sure.
That's not how it works.
Oh, the sugar, yeah.
That's right.
Yeah.
I'm sorry, but we went through that whole area.
There was only one bottle of mouthwash left.
We went through all the boxes of mouthwash?
Swansea won't help, so we'll figure it out ourselves.
Right.
All right.
Yeah, we got this.
But even before the foam, how do we even get the door to utility open?
Swansea has been practically camping in front of us.
of the door and he has the key i have an idea give him more mouthwash you're going to have to trust me we need to knock him out you're gonna fight him oh no even he has his limits when it comes to booze oh wait i was right we're gonna give him the mouthwash we have to make him pass out simple safe like,
Jimmy, the alcohol poisoning is definitely a real thing.
I don't know if safe is the right word.
He might not even realize we did anything after the fact.
There's a recipe for a mocktail in the kitchen.
So we did make the cocktail.
We can follow the steps by using different ingredients to add kick to it.
Come on.
Knock out Swansea.
Okay.
Wait.
It's this door right here.
My bad.
No way.
How am I supposed to get these, though?
Water.
Oh, wait.
Mouthwash.
Isopropyl.
What?
Aww.
Is this it?
We're out of sweetener.
Any ideas?
I, uh...
I might have accidentally at some point mistakenly placed a few packets before.
By accident?
Right.
You could take a look around my stuff, could be somewhere around there.
But also totally somewhere else.
Who knows?
Anything's possible.
Crash sure jumbled everything up.
Right.
I think we would have found it in the four months that we've been here.
No?
I can't believe we're not getting...
We're using our precious isopropyl alcohol for this?
Okay.
Then it's drink, base, and sweetener.
The mouthwash has...
Sugar in it.
Do we need sweetener?
Nice glass.
though oh we took that sweet sweetener but the drink base we don't have that oh oh sorry I'm stupid I for I always forget that the drink base or the base is like the thing we just make okay Vivi core thanks for the gift oh
ah take spiked cocktail this is messed up this is this is messed up who wrote these instructions oh no no
that drink looks sick i could totally picture myself on a beach with a hot babe and a few of those then i drink too many and throw them up all over myself i thought he was gonna say throw them up all over them hot babes and never be able to drink them again good times let's just get this to swansy
Ah, hot babes and good drinks.
You've taken a teaching my intern now?
I personally try to educate based off of years of experience.
But that's just me, Captain.
He says that was such like...
Justane.
Mocktail spiked with isopropyl alcohol.
Here for a good time.
Not a long time.
What is that?
Wait, why does this feel like...
Why does this feel like the mystery of the druid?
How again?
Why do I keep playing games where I'm spiking old men?
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Detective, we must eat the meat.
Wait!
If we eat curly, this will just become the mystery of the druids.
Look, we need to keep working together.
If this is how I can get us through this without us being at each other's necks all the time, then...
Yeah, yeah, give me here.
Why are you continually a pupil without a mentor?
we kind of freestyled the recipe yeah I can tell you had a hand in this monstrosity kid my apple snaps you ain't no mixologist sure as hell ain't no mechanic either you never should have come here who the heck even decided to let you board huh no matter how illegal corrupt or immoral with a bunch of sad sack adults and see what he learns,
eh?
Bootstraps and all that.
What a load of horse shit.
You think it's all going somewhere, but every failure leaves you a little more mangled than before.
Older.
Uglier.
Meaner.
Smarter in a worse way.
Wallowing doesn't suit you, Swansea.
I suppose you think we all should be acting like you.
Our hardworking, esteemed captain.
say take a load off before the sun finally sets on this party.
May we never go to hell, but always be on our way.
Hip-hip!
Hooray!
Oh my gosh, he's just chugging that.
Swansea's key for the utility room and never leaves this person.
Look at the little... Oh, wait, that's so cute!
What does it say on it?
Alright, hey, chill out, dude.
Chill out.
Is he still breathing?
He practically bounced off the ground!
It'll be fine.
His tolerance has to be through the roof by now.
Probably just wake up with a massive headache.
Oh man, he's gonna be so, so mad!
He'll never get a good reference now!
Ow!
Daisuke.
I don't know if we're getting out of this buddy.
Wait, why not?
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Captain, you, uh, are you sure about this?
Maybe we could talk with Swansea when he's cleared up a bit later.
He's just, like, really into workplace safety and stuff sometimes, you know?
Which is, like, totally cool and stuff, I think.
He taught me, it's time to be brave, Daisuke.
Curly and Anya are counting on us.
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
Whoa, it's, like, barely foamed up at all.
it's those things.
I've never been inside one.
What are they called again?
Cryostasis pods.
Oh yeah, these things are far out.
Totally sci-fi.
Still a spare change for the payphone.
Oh, it looks like this one still works.
There's only one working cryostasis pod.
How long can these things even keep you frozen?
20 years.
I can't believe Swansea managed to clear all that foam from here.
I don't think it ever foamed up.
He didn't.
Yeah, he lied.
I mean, I think, you know.
What?
Think about it.
Swansea never let you work with him on breaking the utility room foam walled, right?
No, it needed to be handled delicately.
He said I was way too much...
I have way too much athletic strength in my arms.
Through the foe.
I was like, damn, makes total sense.
Bummer.
Anya keeping a skinless man alive for four months is a medical miracle.
Yeah.
With nothing but, but, like, pain reliever.
So I've been in charge of the kitchen instead.
He said it's...
Oh, sorry.
He said it's next level critical to keep stock and organize every day.
Had me double, triple, four, tuple, check everything, like all the time.
Right.
Of course, and he never told you he'd gotten in here?
No, but look how busy he must have been.
There was never any foam here, and Swansea has known the whole damn time.
Just taking a load off before the sun finally sets on this party, huh?
That boozed up bastard has been biding his time until he can save himself.
Would getting in the pod really mean you'd get rescued?
20 years more of a chance to get found.
I'd take those odds over our current situation.
Not like this, though.
Not by lying through my teeth while waiting for everyone else to die.
No, man, that just can't be right.
I'm sure there's a reason.
We'll ask him about it when he wakes up.
We'll deal with him after.
Right now we have a job to finish.
And the vent looks like it's still in one piece.
Check out those sparks.
Uh-oh.
I hate to imagine how gnarly it looks on the inside.
Gnarly.
Everything's gnarly.
Not, not, not, not, not gnarly.
It could be somewhat collapsed in places.
You could make it through.
We need to try it.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, what?
Um, Swansea said it's not safe.
Yeah, it looks even way less safe now, too.
I know we forgot to tell us about the pod, but he knows, like, everything about this of stuff.
Maybe we should just wait for him to wake back up.
Poor Daisuke!
This poor guy!
You said you could handle it.
Why don't you go in then, Jimmy?
Swansea taught you well, right?
Time to prove it.
He'll be impressed when he wakes up.
Proud.
He'll understand why we had to do this.
Then he can explain himself.
You think so?
Daisuke.
Everyone's counting on you.
Oh my god, Jimmy!
Captain's orders!
Yeah, I got this.
Okay.
Here we go.
Mutiny, mutiny, mutiny!
Oh my god, Jimmy.
What are you doing, Jimmy?
Jimmy!
Daisuke!
What's happening?
What?
Anya?
What did you do?
One day before the crash.
Oh.
Find the gun!
There's a gun on this ship?
Uh, if I were a gun...
Where would I be?
Wait, why are we looking for a gun now?
team
team everything's so clean wow remember oh wow I can't interact with anything anymore okay let's start running
another day in paradise
I already checked here okay let's go back to medical if we started there I imagine maybe it's in there
um like it uh uh oh is that a a box for a gun up there mighty suspicious it's still broken wait she couldn't have hit it in there oh ania ania has the gun uh okay
Utility?
Let's see if anyone's down here.
Where is everybody?
Wait, what was the...
Oh, I can't even interact with it, though.
Because they...
What was the password?
Oh, wait.
This goes circles.
Um...
No?
Cockpit?
Is it in that, um...
What's it called?
The storage locker that we've been getting stuff from?
Oh!
Anya?
Where is it?
Us being let go isn't a reason to hurt yourself.
Anya, as our nurse, you never got psyche vows.
I should have thought of that.
You could have come to me if you were feeling stressed.
What would you have done?
Anything.
You, the crew, are all my responsibility.
I told you so over and over, yeah?
hurt myself you know the gun is in a safety case I can't open but I hid the case itself tell me where it is none of this has has to be on our performance log we'll figure it out together okay I don't think the performance log is what she's thinking of anymore I'm pregnant oh my gosh you're what who would you captain I told you.
Listen to me.
We can fix this.
I've known him for a long time.
I'll talk to him!
I know you'd never give me the gun to protect myself.
So the least I can do is make sure he never gets it either.
She knows he's bad news bears.
Remember when she mentioned the locks?
Yeah!
A reading printed from the navigation computer.
Holy moly.
Holy moly indeed.
Detected abnormal asteroid trajectories along the route.
Course corrections might be required during transit.
She hid it.
Can we remove Jimmy's skin?
And he, this guy is trying to act like he's...
Oh, all like self-important and everything.
Like, I'm the captain, I'm going to get us out of this.
Six hours until judgment.
The bleeding won't stop.
Just try to stay still.
Daisuke.
About stop getting pregnant mid-fantom.
A big congratulations to Hal again.
You are no longer the worst freaking guy.
I need a second to think.
We can fix this.
Hey, kid, do you hear me?
Daisuke?
How did this happen, though?
Hey, stop, stop, stop.
Don't move.
It's all right, Daisuke.
Calm down.
This line of work, you could never have become like miserable old swansy.
What a tragedy.
Decades of hauling ass for Pony Express, big, mighty, Ruzer with all his shiny tools.
This is where it got me.
The good life, huh?
Oh, Daisuke's just a kid.
I thought you were dumber than a can of paint.
Always just chewing my ear off about nothing.
Useless ray of goddamn sunshine.
Yeah, our little golden retriever boy.
Not an A student.
Career workhorse or force of ambition.
Just a damn good kid trying his best.
You could have taught an old fool like me a lot.
Close your eyes, Daisuke.
Cinema.
Oh, my God.
Oh, Swansea.
Oh, shut up, Jimmy.
You monster.
Oh, my gosh.
Jimmy, Huey, oh, yeah, oh gosh, I'm getting like, oh, oh, what is, oh, my brain is mixing people up.
What's happening?
Oh, I could have fixed him, Swansea.
Oh, Jimmy, Jimmy's just a real piece of work now, isn't he?
I have to do everything myself.
Why can't any of you just give me some time to think?
How do you still not understand?
You should be on this boat, Swansea.
Right?
It's over.
End of the fucking line.
He won't suffer one more second because of your delusions.
Unbelievable.
Stop pretending.
I know all about your plan, Swansea.
I went to utility.
on this ship for real that's that pony do you know that swan parents will sometimes kill their young who are weak and sickly really wait that's so sad it's poetry this is somehow Huey's fault I saw what you've been hiding down there sneaking around with that axe telling Anya who knows what Now this,
you're making sure you're the one who gets inside that cryopod.
I sure did talk to Anya.
Jimmy is such an idiot.
Thinking that Swansea is thinking of putting himself in the cryopod.
This guy is so stupid.
But it was her telling me all sorts of things instead, wasn't it?
Shouldn't a captain go down with his ship?
Oh, yeah, you tell him, you tell him.
Not that I'm...
I ain't got no place to be.
I got everything I could ever want right here on this ship.
So go ahead and get in that pot.
If you ever get found, you can tell them whatever fucking story you like.
You've earned it.
Oh, man.
Oh, get the gun!
Wait, I don't know where it is.
Oh, my God!
Okay!
Uh...
Oh...
A gun.
Maybe in medical?
Oh!
Wait!
Uh... Oh!
Oh my god!
Even... We can't even...
What is this?
Oh.
Oh!
Uh...
Is this... The gun?
Uh, is it, um, what's it called?
Oh, wait, I can't, I'll just go this way.
It's just so dark.
I have to use the scanner, right?
Um, oh, wow!
Oh my god.
I wonder where Swansea went.
Like, is he in utility now?
Actually, where could he be?
Is it actually surprising we could come in here?
8008.
You're so right.
Oh!
Yeah, we could brute force it.
We got time.
I don't have time, actually.
This, right?
Right?
739, okay.
It's so quiet.
739, 739.
I can't see.
What can I see?
Okay.
Ah, he's not in here either.
Jeez, Louise.
Oh, my gosh.
I could just hear him breathing while I'm doing this.
Oh,
whoops.
What's the joke I want to know?
I want to laugh, too, Curly.
What if we all just laugh?
Yeah, Jimmy's the joke here.
Jimmy!
Oh!
Is this our judgment?
Wait, what are we?
What are we?
Zero days before the crash.
I was going to say, what could we be zooming to this time?
I told him.
Anya, you...
You should have waited for me.
Oh no, did she tell Jimmy?
What did he say?
Nothing that makes any difference.
Where did he go?
He just walked away.
Curly.
I don't want him in here anymore.
Hold on.
I need to find him.
Everything's going to be okay.
Oh, God.
What's that sound?
I need to go to the cockpit.
Uh, Jimmy.
Jimmy, Jimmy.
Jimmy.
Oh, gosh.
This feels so tense.
Well, there he is.
He's just chilling.
Jim, I can fix this.
What do you think will happen when we get back?
Hmm?
We can figure all this out.
You and me.
All I ever hear is how great of a leader you are.
God, it's so annoying.
But now?
What do you think will happen now when we get back?
We'll fix this together.
Everything you and I worked for in our lives.
Accomplishments.
Changes.
None of it will matter.
Why is Curly getting involved?
What do you mean?
I guess because he's the captain and was supposed to, you know, be taking care of his...
Oh, gosh.
His people.
You've gotten through difficult situations before.
won't be any different.
Work through it one day at a time.
It's not just me, is it?
You were supposed to be the one who had everything under control.
You said so yourself.
Jimmy, I'm Jimmy, I'm sorry, but is Curly puppeteering you?
Does Curly make you do everything?
Jimmy, you have your own actions!
The ship This crew, everything that happened here, this was your responsibility, Captain.
Oh, Jenny!
Oh, that is what you'll be hearing the rest of your life.
Or this can all be remembered as a tragedy.
Despite what must have been the best efforts of its acclaimed captain, never found no one survived to tell the tale oh whoa that's that's curly whoa you're standing at the top feet and cement I get it now right curly with skin I prefer jerky curly right
wait so it was Jimmy's idea to to tank the ship?
Take care of it.
I'll take care of it.
Oh
Wait, so Jimmy was the one who did it.
Oh my oh my god.
Oh my god Ah Oh, wrong way Oh
my gosh Ah
Jimmy!
Jim, tell me you didn't.
Oh my god, Curly, you do what you...
I didn't...
What did you do?
One hour before judgment.
Who is...
Wait.
What happened to...
What did they do to Anya?
Wait, with Anya's body also.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, but where's Swansea?
Wait.
Birthday.
Oh no.
Oh, put you in the chair.
Oh, no.
Happy birthday, Captain.
This rocks.
I'm here, here.
To Captain Jimbo.
Oh, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Come on.
You have to give a speech.
Go on.
Have at it.
You better make it good.
yeah our captain captain jimmy oh wow this is so dumb
um i'd like to dedicate i'd like to dedicate this meal to my trusted mentor detective haligan whom has taught me everything that i've ever known and that i take his teachings at very face value
I accidentally touched the leave.
I accidentally opened the developer menu?
My bad.
Okay.
Get the job done.
I even got an achievement for opening the developer menu.
I don't know how I did that.
I kind of keyboard smash for a second.
Oh, just do it fast.
Just do it fast.
Just get it through it.
AHHHHH!
No.
A lot of people struggle to put food on their plates.
That wasn't enough.
Right, Captain?
The lowest rung of your ladder is our highest.
Until it was all swept from under your feet.
Jimmy is such a freak!
Muy, muy, cute!
Life isn't even worth living at the same level as us.
But I forgive you.
All of us do.
I won't give up on you.
Even like this.
we're going to make it through this oh there's the there's everyone gets their peace oh my gosh and all their bodies are like slumped over no yeah freak derogatory not like you guys unless you're also taken after mr halogen sometimes we thrive travel the endless reaches of space but other times We just have to accept days like these.
You taught me that, Curly.
Let's eat.
Let's survive.
Take responsibility!
What's happening?
Oh.
Why is it all messed up?
Wee!
I am.
I still don't quite get how Daisuke got injured though.
Soup.
Chess.
I can't see anything.
Oh, there we go.
Injured in the vent.
Yeah, but like, I don't know.
I guess just machinery, something cut him up.
Oh, that's freaky.
Oh, that's good.
Oh!
Danger.
Hands off, idiots!
The flower from the drink.
This game has great visuals.
Well, turning back now.
Oh.
Oh,
that's cool!
What do I do, though?
That is a cool effect.
Oh, walk backwards.
Like one of those typical horror game moments.
It looked like a face, right?
You're lost.
Oh.
I can't look at it.
It's his hands and his like stuff, his little dumbbells and his Game Boy.
Responsibility.
It's a big theme in this game.
Hi.
Take it.
Want to take the Game Boy?
Oh!
Oops.
I guess I can keep walking.
Do I keep... I'm just running away from my problems.
You have to take it.
Yeah, I'm backing away.
Oh, I take respawn.
I'm running away from my responsibility.
Oh, it's getting loud.
Cool.
It was just so much longer than I expected.
Of having to run backwards.
Where are we?
Utility is still missing.
Hmm.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, I kind of wanted to see the flower!
It looked nice.
Oh, all the axes?
Oh, it's getting real spooky, you guys.
I'm scared.
Is that us or is there someone else crawling?
Like the heartbeat sound too is...
Okay, yeah, there's definitely something else.
Someone else?
Another thing?
In the... in here?
Okay.
Nothing here?
Alright.
Freaky.
It's just rats.
this is rats and dice game
I didn't I mean I knew that like it would be bleak you know for everybody considering the situation in general but like I didn't I thought Anya was gonna I thought Anya was gonna live what was that I
At least.
Swansea!
No.
Looking at him.
Looking at me.
Personal protection weapon.
Issued to captains in case of unrest amongst the crew.
I don't even get to talk to him.
No.
way what if i shoot uh here oh you missed how could you miss whoa where are we
my ears though a ringing felt real what is okay i'm gonna turn it down in case i have to use the gun again for all of our sakes Oh, I think I'm going to have to.
Wait, a zombie game?
What?
What is...
This is so freaky!
What is this?
Beloved friend.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
I almost did not make that.
Oh my god.
I hear him.
I missed.
I
was totally camping.
I'm sorry.
I have something to say.
So shut up and listen.
I spent 13 years half cut up to my eyeballs.
Drunk, to put it mildly.
Then suddenly I saw it, a streetlight shining in my face.
500 gigawatts of the power of God.
A vision of my bloated body found in some ditch.
Scared me straight.
So I got a collar shirt, mortgage, and a credit card.
All the things that make me a good man.
I hoped I could raise my children to be better than their old man.
I wanted to believe I was never one setback away from my worst self.
But the truth is, discipline, drive, routine, the endless desperation to get shit done.
A loving wife, right kids, sobriety, I'm telling you.
you you accomplishments I've been chasing all my life never felt as good as I expected when I crossed the finish line so now that we're at the end take an inventory those nights spinning out of my of my head sinking into the sofa broken glass in my palms bleeding dry the funniest thing ever old dogs laughing and snarling on a waterbed floor mocking the moon for daring to show its face all nausea and wreckage and vomit and ugly cruelty the only problem in the world the only problem in the world an empty bottle those were the best days of my life yeah those were the best days of my life I've I got nothing to hide ready to face the music I can see myself for what am are you a cowardly selfish motherfucker and you can't even see it I should have been able to protect the kid if I have could if I could have done one thing right I wish I had been to give him one small chance off this goddamn rock oh my Oh my god,
Jimmy.
Swatzy.
I'm going to fix everything.
We're going to make it.
Fuck you.
Take responsibility.
Oh, yeah, I swear when I mean it.
I don't want to just say it all the time.
Only when it really is a...
What is that?
A picture of a dog?
What?
Almost all the foam is gone.
I just realized.
We're still in mind...
Illusion world.
If you check the pod before you shot Swansea, It would be full of Daisuke's heads.
Yeah, wait!
What pod before I shot him?
There was no pod.
Was there?
Whoa, whoa.
You know how they talk about cable management for computers?
This shit means pipe management.
Curly.
That's freaky.
Oh, hey!
Whoa, the walls are growing eyeballs!
Oh, I'm getting dizzy.
Whoa!
Every box in front of fries at Arby's has one big curly.
Ah!
I'm in...
I'm...
Oh.
Uh...
I hope this isn't at the intestines.
Intestines?
Maybe this is the throat.
I'm just gonna run through here.
Oh, the audio in this game is so good.
Holy heck, it's so good.
Oh, we were in the throat.
This is the mouth.
I
hear like other footprints or not footprints but footsteps along with mine.
Do you guys hear it?
Curly.
What is this?
Oh!
Okay, hold on.
It is all Mother Goose's birthday.
We're giving her a party.
A party, a party, a party for Mother Goose.
The baker man, he served the cake.
Wait, why is like the cursor in the TV?
You see this?
Take Curly's leg
Okay Oh
the children
That's a potato I could go for a potato right now I love baked potato It's people Oh gosh you guys have been playing way too many games.
I can reference multiple games about eating people.
I have played so many games about cannibalism recently that I can reference multiple games.
Can I leave?
Okay, we took his leg.
Oh my gosh.
This is... I don't quite understand what the puzzle is.
Um...
Oh!
Ah!
Does it like change the TV or anything?
Someday he'll thank me!
Oh my god!
Wait.
I need to get closer?
Oh my god, no, no, no way!
No, what?
Oh my god!
Wait, I didn't notice...
Okay, I only saw it.
I didn't see where it started at all.
Oh, his mouth is closed.
My bad.
Open wide!
Okay, where's it start?
Okay, up there.
Ah!
Okay, hi.
So this was right before...
Oh, this is a little confusing.
Okay.
Good thing he throws up the whole chunk, right?
If I had a nickel for every time I play a game featuring cannibalism, I'd have two nickels.
Nope.
Skunk face, I'd have three!
Okay, it starts there, it goes up.
Oh.
Uh-oh, did I mess up?
Okay.
How am I supposed to turn this one though?
Wait, what's this one turn?
Okay, that.
Uh...
I had it going to this one, so I'm kind of just like, dang it, I had it.
Hold on, let's try again.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, there, oh, just kidding.
Okay, up.
No, okay, this one needs to turn.
Okay.
Stop being so dramatic, buddy.
Yeah, good thing.
Maybe he needs a mooy-mooy cube for his meal.
What?
Wait, but I had...
Is it this bottom one that was messed up?
But it went...
Bottom left needs to go up.
Okay.
So it is now.
Okay, hold on.
Sorry, I'm figuring it out.
Okay, through there.
Through there.
Up there.
Okay.
Ah!
It might... Okay, so this one hasn't been touched yet.
So it's one of the... So it has to be this one that needs to be moved.
Most likely.
Oh, oops.
Oh, I forgot to grab it.
Thank you so much for the rhythm break.
Sorry, you came in at the, like, the craziest time.
Four games?
Peak had it, too.
Oh, wait.
I didn't eat anybody in Peak.
Okay, here.
Ah!
Uh.
Alright, let's change that.
Okay.
We're getting this.
Oh, my bad.
Open up.
It's losing its effect because I'm like stuck on the puzzle, you know?
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Through and...
Ah!
I think we did it!
Oh, just kidding.
Thank you guys so much for the gifted.
Thank you.
All right.
This is the final version.
Final version.
All right.
Alright, eat up!
Eat up, Curly!
I think of music.
Into your tummy.
Help me.
He's trapped in space!
Oh,
I'm controlling him.
My little video game man.
Whoa!
No matter what key I hold, by the way, he just walks forward, so...
Look at him.
Like he's walking a runway.
Oh, Jimmy.
Man on fire.
Jimmy Quest.
Oh!
Why are you on fire now, girl?
Oh, well, I guess that's what happened to make all this skin, you know, come off, huh?
I want to go home.
We are home.
Oh, my gosh.
Chippy.
The red light is just making...
Why don't you finish what you started?
Don't worry if anyone ever finds us.
I'll still be playing the villain.
Curly.
you'll be the better man in the end like you wanted curly is almost just as bad as Jimmy is I could have stopped it I'm taking responsibility no we can both be heroes we're a team just you and me like we used to be
what happened was an accident we were trapped i made a mistake all right i'm sorry i'm so sorry curly
no we're back in the vents Take responsibility.
The vents have been upgraded a little bit.
Oh, I have a thing.
What is it searched for?
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
Probably just destroyed the bitrate.
Oh.
What?
What am I looking for in here?
A baby?
Am I looking for a way to get inside or...
Oh,
I heard a heartbeat.
I wish I could run.
Like...
I'm so close to the sound.
It feels like at least.
What?
Oh, it...
What am I looking for?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is!
Um...
What the hell?
Oh, I saw- I thought I- I think I saw it.
There it is!
No, but this is how your Uma Musume is born.
The baby's from the beginning.
Oh my gosh, I almost forgot about them.
All clean.
I hope this hurts.
Really gets rid of that bad taste in your mouth, huh?
Through wreckage.
Through silence.
Wash it away.
All day fire fresh.
Oh.
Oh, it's the pieces of the horse.
I'm sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no.
Is this like another boss?
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Do I have to be quiet again like before?
Oh my gosh.
Scared the heck you out of me.
Oh my god.
I'm just running.
Oh gosh.
I'm running into darkness.
Oh, what are these?
Oh, everybody's employee cards.
What are you trying to tell me?
Is the horse supposed to get you?
Oh yeah, sorry if the bitrate here is like craziness.
Whoa.
Okay.
Kind of ASMR.
I'm so on edge now!
From the horse!
You!
From you!
Oh, hey Polly!
Pony Express is dead.
And so are you.
Hey, boss!
Polly says...
Oh.
Sorry.
Shut up.
Curly tried his best.
I did too.
But he's the better man.
I see that now.
We can both still make it.
I'll take care of him.
I'm taking responsibility.
Curly, Captain, I'm so sorry.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes, I do.
For now, thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I messed up.
We can still make this right.
Thank you so much for the 20 games.
Thank you!
What the heck?
Thank you both so much.
Our worst moments don't make us...
I like the voice effect on Polly so much.
It's so cool.
Zero hours before judgment.
I have them.
How are you still alive?
There's no way.
There's no way!
Wait, oh, okay, that's her turtleneck.
I thought, like, okay, okay.
I thought her, like, neck was bulging or something, creepy.
Curly feels like he's alive out of pure spite.
Where are we going?
Rain?
Go home?
Utility.
Wait.
No.
this guy is not going to make it we're gonna cradle him like a baby in here with us
oh my god he didn't even get in
it's okay curly you're going to be okay oh my god this is jimmy's solution for fixing it you always had my back i ended up hurting you even though i was trying to save us But now you'll survive.
It's like you said.
Together we can fix anything.
I think Jimmy's a yandere for Curly.
Oh my god!
I'm just proud I got to be your friend and co-pilot.
Captain!
No one can hurt you now.
We fixed it.
Don't be like I fixed it!
What
are you gonna do then?
That's what he's gonna do.
We did it, Patrick.
We saved it.
Did he turn on the pod?
Oh.
Oh, he did.
He did.
Oh, my God.
He literally...
He just doomed this guy.
Mystery of the mouthwash.
Ah!
Oh my god!
He doomed this guy to a horrible life.
If he ever gets rescued.
Glad you got to play this game in tow.
Thank you!
Camp Patrol, thank you so much for the pink.
Wow, oh my god.
Oh, I can't move my head anymore.
Oh!
Wow, wow, I'm sad that almost that I like put off this game for so long now.
Wow, yeah, I'm frozen.
I'm just gonna be a little jerky curly for the rest of my...
Who has... Nobody has this much skin to skin graft me.
Kind of makes that Anya Nendo a bit grim.
Oh, well, I mean...
I think tragic characters and characters from tragic series are made into toys all the time.
I mean, you can get the nurses from Silent Hill, too.
Thanks for playing!
Follow us, quit.
I'm guessing this is like Twitter.
Jimmy or Huey?
Um, oh gosh, they're both real bad.
Oh, I just clicked quit.
My bad.
Wow.
Wee.
Made my friend play it yesterday.
She said I hated that.
It was a good game, but I hated that here.
I'll go to the void, so I'm not like...
It's so dark.
Have you finally played this game?
Yeah!
me fixed it frozen jerky oh and then he cuts off his leg before that too i just the guy is bleeding out no i'm so i'm so huh oh
wow first time seeing this never expected to be so heavy i've always seen like people talk like kind of you know how like okay i i feel like if i say this you might understand what i mean where it's like okay and i don't mean it in this way hold on i'm gonna put on some music
um so not a meme i never really saw memes of it i always saw it as like a tumblr game and what i mean by that is like the certain kind of fan base that it garnered i guess like how they act felt like, you know, they were like, I don't know, I don't know how to describe it.
I thought it was really good.
And I just mean that, I don't mean that in terms of like the way the game is.
I mean that in the way, like how the fan base kind of took the series.
Because I never really saw so much of like fan art or anything like that, but I would see certain like fan arts that I would be like, oh, Reminds me of a Tumblr game.
I don't know how else to describe it.
Like Undertale.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
So.
I didn't see it.
I really, honestly, like, I know I saw fan art because I remember seeing it, but I don't...
One, I didn't have context for anything, so I don't know what it meant.
And two, I don't remember any of it because it was so long ago.
hmm but
our tumblr games bad or good I don't mean it in that it's really just the way that the fan base acts towards the game it doesn't have a reflection on the game itself in my when I'm describing it when I'm describing it I mean it in a way that's like how the fan base acts about it not the game itself because I really like undertale i liked this there are some fandoms though that they are a little overzealous for my for for me so i oops it's not that i don't i don't really participate in a lot of fandom stuff anyway so i don't know i i kind of just like i like what i like and then i kind of just stay in my own bubble with it so that which i think honestly probably metal gear is the only thing that i've because,
like, I go to stuff like MGSCon, but then, even then, I just kind of go for the experience, and I don't really talk to anybody.
So, I don't know.
I'm just always in my own bubble kind of deal.
I don't talk to people very much.
I'm a ghost.
I'm just, I'm just haunting in the background.
You go for the game, not the fan base.
Yeah.
Of course it's always fun.
I feel like it would be fun to talk to and everything about it but yeah anyways guys that was fun fun fun fun thank you for hanging out with me thanks
for the stream yeah this was a little heavier it was a little heavier of a spooky game this time but hopefully you still had fun with it um you know even with heavy game so i try to at least keep uh keep spirits uh hi onto the concert yeah exactly club iron mouse i i will be uh a small little opener i club iron mouse so um but they're currently having tech issues so um yeah I'm...
Um...
Yen Wei, thank you so much!
Did you know that good smile is taking pre-orders for the onion?
Yeah!
Wait, actually, now I'm gonna go look at the onion underwood.
Uh...
Is it on Ami Ami already?
Let's see.
I don't see it.
Oh, I do see it.
Just kidding.
Let's see what it...
Oh my god!
Okay, it's a really good thing I didn't look at this beforehand.
Hold on for anybody who did not see it yet.
Are you...
Wow!
They have no chill.
For real!
Look at this!
I'm so...
I'm honestly surprised there's not little pill bottles that come with it.
This is messed up.
You always make cannibalism so fun.
Oh!
Wow!
Wait!
I have another game that I can add to my complete game list.
So now we're at...
Let's see.
10.
16, 20, 25.
Mouthwashing.
We're at 30 games!
I have 20 more games that I need to beat to hit my goal of 50 for the year.
It does not come with a pillbox.
bottle.
It comes with the little mouthwashing, though.
The Nendorite is so cute, too.
She looks so cute.
It's just messed up.
Looking forward to...
Oh, wait.
Did you notice that Polly and Anya had the same mint-colored text?
Oh, no, I didn't, actually.
Wait, I thought she was light blue.
Who am I thinking of as light blue?
Okay.
Pill model is a Good Smile exclusive!
Oh my gosh, also Dwarco, thank you so much for the pink!
That's true, but I'm with you, an evil protagonist in Legcat of Elizabeth Hawkeye.
This game was just Mystery of the Druids in disguise.
Wait, I have to go see the Good Smile.
Hot dog.
Let's see, Good Smile Company.
Congrats, Anya, for dethroning the previous most upsetting Nendo.
Chirase at her mother's laptop.
Oh, my God, that one is messed up.
It's always, like, so comical because they're like little baby, little baby, you know.
Oh, wow, this Ghost in the Shell figure is so cool.
They're like little chibi babies.
And then you get this.
Oh, my gosh, the bonus is the...
Oh, it's the painkillers.
And then also there's another bonus, which is the moon background.
And then there's another bonus, which is...
Food?
What?
This must be just a regular bonus.
That, like, a bunch of things.
Because that has nothing to do with mouthwashing.
It comes with a... It's like pizza and sushi and rice and donuts and takoyaki.
Huh?
Looking forward to the next new game history.
Can't wait how we'll be eating human meat then.
Recommend more...
More cannibal games for me, everybody.
Also, look at this Makoto Kusanagi figure.
Oh, I said Makoto.
Sorry, Motoko.
I always get her name wrong.
I'm so sorry.
Fake Ghost in the Shell fan.
Look at this, though.
Look at it.
Wow.
It looks so good.
Good, so good.
Wow.
It's so cool.
I'm like obsessed with it.
I only watched Standalone Complex, though.
I haven't watched any of the new stuff.
And that looks like older art, too.
But I think there was a new anime that adapted the older art, no?
What?
That's so bad.
I love Ghosts in the Shell.
Yeah.
Watch the movies, yeah?
Old movies are good.
Maybe I did watch them, though, but, like, a long, long time ago.
When I was a kid.
But standalone complex, opening still one of the best anime openings, in my opinion.
Okay, I am going to...
I'm going to head out now I'm in the middle of watching standalone complex How timely
Thank you guys so so much If I do Russian I would sing it But I don't know I don't want to butcher it Thank you everybody Thank you thank you Thank you for hanging out With me today And I will see you guys When I see you next Puppets.
I'm going to attempt to make puppets.
My hair's been purple for the past couple of years.
I've been inspired by you to finally change it to mid-grid.
Oh my gosh, Melody!
It's going to be so beautiful.
Glisterk, happy birthday!
Sorry, I'm a little late.
Happy, happy birthday!
Thank you, everybody!
Otsumito!
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time.
zone if you are watching sub iron mouse see you there and yeah enjoy the rest of your day or night or whatever time it is for you it's the last time bye bye thank you bye